hello everyone and welcome today we are
playing mini motorways I absolutely love
this game but I previously actually only
played it on iOS
um it is a very good time something
about it I find it so incredibly
satisfying uh a very big thank you to
Dinosaur Polo Club for sponsoring this
stream slash gameplay
um they have given me the updated
version which is the first update for
this game since challenge City in 2021
which if you played this game before I'm
sure you're familiar with
and it includes endless and expert modes
um so let's see if I can get to unlock
expert mode here because uh I think it's
here um I can't just yet because I have
to complete 600 trips
um so we might be able to get to that in
this stream
and again if you don't know expert mode
is basically just like the hardest
version of this game that's ever existed
in this game can be challenging
um
plus the endless mode is almost the
opposite endless mode lets you build and
create a bustling cityscape for any road
loving hearts desires with no
game-ending conditions so basically the
opposites
um but if yeah if you haven't played it
before again it's my first time playing
on PC and it has been a minute but I do
really love this game so
let's do it let's jump right into Los
Angeles that's where I'm from well not
from that's where I live the core
concept is simple
you connect things
and at first it's very calming and
relaxing and you watch the car drive
from the point to the other point I'm
also I don't think I'm good at this game
am I gonna finish Shadows of rose on
stream sometime yes it's just been very
busy which you know
all the Ragnarok stuff quite consuming
thank you vampiric Acorn and crew 7 plus
appreciate you
thank you
um
so yeah you guys will figure out what it
is that that this game was about pretty
quick and again it starts off very easy
right now we just have
four cars trying to get to this nice
yellow building
Los Angeles has never oh I don't need to
do that has never looked like this never
there is absolutely no way
thank you Soul Santana can you hear some
commentary in my American accent
foreign
do you mean my valley girl accent maybe
at some point it's better if I pull it
out casually though okay
[Music]
do over here
and I guess put you like here which
may be a bad idea
um
but you can only use so many roads I've
already got a bridge
does that mean someone's already gonna
spawn over this way
surely not
surely not
a huge yellow dragon
La soccer 1800s 100 yeah so it like it
can always seem weird that I just did
that but that's me trying to prevent
these two from overlapping too much
because the traffic can get pretty
hectic
um I live in L.A I've known
and my suggestion for anyone wants to
play this game again I've mostly played
it on iOS it's a really really great
um Bubble Game
is like it's just a really good commute
game which is funny because it's about
traffic
I wish La had walkable neighborhoods my
guy okay
traffic lights and a roundabout I'm
gonna go with the traffic lights
not that I need either just yet
everything's fine right now
what else are you gonna throw at me my
friend
and again I think I'm maybe bad at this
game I'm sure there are like videos of
people who have beautifully laid out
grids
um
I don't think I'm very good at it
but I'm doing my best
oh that did that just auto connect
well that's convenient I don't even have
to do anything
thank you Wookie hammer
banjo hope you had a great day they keep
you so I did think I do think banjo had
a great day today
you know he went for a walk for a whole
hour after he got his surgery it took a
really long time before we were allowed
to walk him for a long periods of time
and uh he used to only be able to walk
for five minutes
back then slowly increased to 10. today
was his first time ever going for an
hour walk
and he was very tired
but um the fact that we've got him to a
point where he can do that is real nice
I think he had a great time
[Music]
okay nothing else has spawned yet right
no because these two really just saved
my skin by just
well I wonder if maybe doing that would
also
I just don't need to yet I'm Gonna Save
the roads
because in my head I could like oh you
can't connect those two I could do like
a grid
there we go
where's the blue houses though
I don't even see any blue houses
I'm gonna put you here
um knew it and then
do I have enough roads to pull this off
I do
beautiful
that's a long commute though that you've
got
like I could have done it up this way
could I have no it has it has to go like
that
it's an entrance
oh but
well okay
um
maybe up the top here
yeah that seems okay
Mountain dewkin don't know how much
involvement you had in God of War 2 or
Ragnarok but congrats nonetheless thank
you not much but I did work on it and I
am honored to be able to say that it's
so cool to have that be a part of my
life at all that's it rules but very
little
uh uh what would I like to upgrade 30
Road tiles traffic lights and 20
reptiles
[Music]
I'm gonna go the road times because I
just used like a fair few of them and I
don't know that like we could put a
traffic light
there what's our busiest intersection
here
probably that one right now because the
blue has to go through there
why not
did I you I used the bridge there right
that just Auto Bridges I think
my my okay that's a long commute too
this is gonna get hairy right here
because
um
it's these Blues I okay I think I want
to take you out of this whole system in
general to be honest I think I want to
do this
we need a new bridge for it so I can't
yet oh I'm sorry
I didn't mean to do that
if I can get
or should I just erase that bridge
I can do it yeah
sorry Lads I'm getting rid of everything
oh it won't let me
okay maybe not yet
maybe I'll erase that when I get another
Bridge that's what I'm thinking or is it
even gonna let me go there I might have
to like loop back and go up
you can get roundabouts in taikwa I just
didn't I did not opt to get the
roundabouts
yet
this is right on Santa Monica Bay one of
these buildings is where you work
that's office to be honest it is kind of
close
could you build a road above the water
then delete the bridge
no I don't think so
okay
this makes me think I need to keep these
roads anyway
for this oh geez
oh whoa I didn't mean to do that we
don't we we can we we did not need all
of this
uh uh okay
um
grid
put you just straight across
don't love what's happened there
who has a clock
oh nothing okay Bridge Motorway
um foreign
[Music]
if I can just go whoop
again oh my God what am I doing
just straight across because I think
that'll save the commute for this guy
and then
let's make this tidier as well you just
go straight up
you go across now
foreign
because I think that that takes you down
right
[Music]
this one at least
should
help question mark unsure not confident
and what I am saying
yeah I forgot that you can rotate houses
um
which would help but I don't remember
how to do it uh
I do not remember how to do it it did it
did tell me that before
um
I should Google that thank you yo it'so
how to rotate houses
is everyone okay everyone's okay
um how to rotate building in mini
motorways
you can change my anytime Joy Road from
the opposite side of a house you can
make that house point a different
direction
wait wait wait wait wait you mean I just
I can just I just draw the road
[Music]
very easy okay oh no
sorry my guy
um and then we're just gonna do that
then
okay
so far away
yeah you need to still go through there
so this guy we can just do this and then
get rid of that
this guy
is actually easier if we just do that
yes
foreign
can stay you need to be rotated too
[Music]
let's do another bridge I'm not running
out of Road towels just yet so
we good there
[Music]
is okay otherwise I think
let's just make this straight just
because
that seems nice
so you'd go up that way and you go down
that way
I like it
beautiful
yeah
looks like one of those games that on
the surface looks calming but deep down
is super stressful you're not wrong my
friend it is calming like the sound is
very calming
getting resources is calming but as you
get further into the levels it can get
extremely stressful
um I do really enjoy it though
it's probably easiest to pull all of
these down right
and just build your
right across here
like that
I think
[Music]
because that's where they all are
you are going to come down this way
you are gonna go right up this way
green where's the greenhouse oh buddy
miles away
oh no
[Music]
hmm
I'm gonna get you all probably this
this way and then we need another road
just like through here I think
you just go whoop whoop whoop that's not
that bad
these guys have the easiest trip to work
the reds are chill too
yeah
doing all right doing all right
you finally got the don't play Stanley
Parable for five years achievement it's
such a funny achievement I love that
it's great
I love gonna be good
okay I'm gonna do a Motorway
I don't think I need it quite yet and so
is do we have any other places where
mixing up traffic would be helpful
here
this is sort of a traffic jam
obviously the traffic lights are doing a
lot of work there but
there
yeah maybe there
which I can always move it but for now
I'm gonna do right
here
I think
uh what just popped up okay
a bit odd but
you know keeping the family together
[Music]
hang on that was a bad idea let me go
the other way
because then you can just go right down
here
yeah okay feeling good about it those
three blue houses across from the dark
blue and the red offices are awkward
three blue houses oh these guys yeah
maybe they should go down
maybe all of the Blues should be going
down
because they do have a lot of weird work
to do here huh they're just sort of they
gotta go oh because it's up there though
too
um all right bud where are we gonna put
you
just tore down a tree for that one
we can put them back this way
right
it's it's weird no matter what I think
yeah I feel like it's weird no matter
what
it's a good lesson in Wise Subways are a
good idea definitely
uh
okay
yeah I wonder if there's a way I can
organize this better
or if there's somewhere I should put it
like maybe I can mode away
these guys like I don't also don't
remember exactly how to use a Motorway
because
um Motorway you drag it yeah okay so you
you drag it
um
this will get all the blues over Foster
is my plan right
just take the Blues from here and just
drag them over there
seems hard oh I should have taken the
road tiles
foreign
yeah now all these Blues have an easier
job
I'm gonna make this one connect here
rather than there
and this one here rather than there and
this one here rather than there and then
the yellows do you need to go out
anywhere no you still got to go up
this blue can go down too
just too
seems good seems good I feel good about
it
do we need another Motorway somewhere
the congestion here is certainly a
problem but that's because too many
people decided to live here okay that
seems like a you problem not a me
problem that's all I'm saying and I
don't think I can connect these can I
no because it has to be the entrance of
the building
um
that's a mess but okay
Motorway for green that's true the
greens yeah but they're not they're okay
um
because the Green Path isn't too bad
like it's not a short distance but they
don't have a lot of traffic
to get there the blues did
I wonder if I would get rid of this I
can get that blue up there fosterone I
think I can
just go whoop whoop what what
and that will go there uh that blue yeah
no that's fine
well why don't I just then also do this
just get rid of all that
is a pretty busy street here
um
I feel good about it I feel good about
it you can connect houses diagonally too
can you okay
roundabout or a bridge
let's do the bridge
so wait I can connect houses diagonally
wait so I could have done that oh that's
way better
yeah because otherwise it's a bunch of
roads for just one guy
um
I think there's anything else I really
need to do right now
got two Bridges at the moment something
will surely spawn over here at some
point too
you have some tiles on the red house on
the right taken by the one at the top of
the red house on the right
this one
um
I could do that I put it this way
to let it avoid the green
um more than anything
I'm okay with that being that that way
loving the motorway maybe I should give
the redso mode away the Green's a
Motorway
we could try a moto I don't know how
long the motorways can be but I'm
thinking if I can get a mud away from
here to here
well there's just not that much traffic
there
still not that much of a problem
uh let's do this a little differently
I knew it
okay can I change the entrance of no
these entrances have to stay yeah
all right this is where we're gonna put
in
our new bridge
what a great commute I have given you my
my
um
damn shame about this one
because like they're all just gonna go
there now
um
you can have a little nice drive by the
river my friend
oh the blue
oh uh we have to do that like like that
okay
yeah okay so when it has these little
icons show up that means that um there's
like a task there so the greens still do
have to go there
we've not avoided that
can I give a Motorway for these Reds
because this has got a lot of um
I'm gonna do this one right now
oh boy
okay
this is a problem
uh okay okay okay
we gotta get these Reds off of these
Blues
by doing that
this is just going to be a busy
intersection but I have a roundabout
there
put that there
and that should help
down here what are you doing sir
anyway yo stopped
okay
still got that Motorway is there any
goal media trying to maintain uh so it's
about tasks completed um you have to
complete a certain amount of tasks I
think it's
900
800.
which I'm just waiting for
because right now obviously
uh these individual beacons here are
tasks so
oh no
Motorway
this is a problem here obviously
a significant problem
oh you are in trouble and you are in
trouble
how can I get the dark blues that faster
I feel like there needs to be another
road here
the dark Blues my gosh
like is there a way to fix it this can
just this particular congestion
does that help
maybe a little
no it's still bad
too many people need it
um okay let's do another Motorway
and just
add in another road just to see like
what if I do like like this
uh
oh my gosh
stop yeah
um
getting anything out of here is hard
that helped a little
damn
my whole city is shut down all right
we're gonna keep trying
oh that comes at you fast man
more Lanes doesn't mean less traffic
ever yeah you're probably not wrong
we're gonna I
whenever I play this I always go I'm
gonna go with a grid system and then it
never ends up staying as a grid system
[Laughter]
[Music]
but it's okay
we'll get there
I still
very thoroughly enjoy playing it
and I think maybe I need to rebuild more
often as well
that might help
you say grid system is a trap
but then you've not been to Adelaide
one of Australia's most boring most
beautiful and most beautifully organized
cities the whole city is like a
three-lane grid system it's incredible
like a work of art
unbelievable
to be fair this is Los Angeles
um which does mean
grid system what grid system
I think I'm already breaking the grid
system by doing this am I not
sort of
it's British
I'm not from Sydney what are you talking
about
oh that's awesome chaos cluster
the people building houses randomly
that's the problem I agree can you turn
the Office Buildings I don't think you
can
uh you can change the houses
but not the buildings
thank you my nose milk uh will I be
doing another podcast with Yong and
skillet they were great yeah we do them
like every three months or so I imagine
we'll probably do one
start of December probably talking about
Game of the Year stuff I would guess
let's let's go not that I need any of it
yet come on now
[Music]
too easy my friend too easy
yeah I think the entrances for the
buildings stay the same no matter what
you just kind of have to work with them
the bridge yet do I
I do have a single Bridge
[Music]
um
grid system
we're still trying this is definitely
gonna become a problem in time
[Music]
The Deadly Premonition series and
Funhouse and when we finish the game
I'm going in next week to record another
episode
we'll get there
I wish this house was just a little bit
further back
that would be real nice
[Music]
when can we expect Mark better down on
the channel he's writing in game right
I've already had a mark on my YouTube
channel he's already been on a podcast
but yeah I don't doubt that I will
eventually have him on writing 101.
right now on that show I am trying to
um
don't think so I'm trying to
uh have it be
more to do with like new game releases
um
which is very tough to schedule
just be going okay so far
this is just gonna make this a disaster
um
like
it's almost worth going around no that's
too much effort it's just this is a slow
Street
I do feel like we're gonna need to
change it eventually
that down there that doesn't make any
difference really
no
this is just a it's just a lot of cars
pulling in and off you know
traffic lights and Road tiles or just
Road tiles
that's your traffic lights I'm all right
with Road tiles right now
why would you build a house behind a
house
this game makes me understand why
different public service departments
hate each other
uh you know what my friend
straight down
which is only tough if you want to get
if you want to get to there
that's a bit of a challenge you
[Music]
maybe also
I think that you need to go like that
you
need to
go like that it's really the only option
for you my friend and then you have to
go straight up
I wonder if maybe I need more roads like
just more options
like even if it seems nuts if I just
draw a path through there is that gonna
help did the cause know to avoid the
traffic
and here
best way to win this game is to
segregate based on colors as much as
possible I don't know that you can do
that though also we don't support that
here but I don't know that you really
can because
these two are split
so no matter what
I I yeah it they'll be very hard to do
unless I just make a bunch of direct
routes
foreign
causing uncommon traffic to slow down
jerks
well this sucks
that's a real issue that you've just
created there
okay
oh oh all right oh God
rip grid system bro we tried all right
we tried um what am I gonna do with you
two
shiza
I just have to do this right now
it just it just has to be what it is
right now
oh Motorway Motorway Motorway Motorway
where would the motorway be most helpful
is the question
these two to that right
or just anything to make it this faster
um I'm not sure yet
can you go around the top end of the
river yes but
um I don't know that that would I mean
it might save time let's just draw it
out I have the roads to do it
just you know just more roads just more
roads just add more roads
why not
this is not good
okay
I need another Bridge
I definitely need another bridge I'm
also going to take you out of this
equation actually and you
um for now
or maybe we keep all of it so you have
the option to go
this way
to there or this way to there
more roads oh no
foreign
I think
let's see do I just like I just drag it
from here
all the way
to there
I think that helps
like it'll alleviate these houses at
least
thank you
and some of the Reds
is there a way to help these yellows out
maybe if I
uh let's take the bridge bridge will
help
just do whatever that is just more roads
man okay bridge is gonna go from here
just take that down
this still doesn't have a path out
take
um how many only five that's not good
okay
[Music]
things are flowing okay
at this point that's blowing okay
[Music]
thank you you're deviant and shallows am
I planning another fun house
collaboration beside daily premonition
nothing planned at this stage no but I
mean obviously I love
pretty much everyone there so
[Music]
uh could use more routes do we want to
put a traffic light somewhere
[Music]
you know I think if we're actually doing
pretty good right now the motorway
helped a lot
[Music]
it's okay
because it really was these getting over
there was was the tough one
[Music]
um
[Music]
yeah we're doing all right whoa thank
you shallows thank you so much for the
gifted subs thank you
oh thank you for the raid Clara thank
you everybody I appreciate you I'm
playing mini motorways uh the stream is
sponsored by the wonderful people
at dinosaur Polo Club I really love this
game
um as stressful as it definitely is
that seems fine
you
are a bit of a punk but
oh no
I don't have enough roads for you okay
we're gonna have to get rid of
these extra ones I built
just to add them in here
uh you need that road to get home
what else can I get rid of
thank God
which
I want the mode away real bad I really
want the motorway
but the road tiles
I think I have to
okay
that's a hell of a commute you guys have
though I wonder if I could
add whatever I did back here back in
because it
think I think helped
nobody's timing out so it did something
uh you gotta go up here
but can maybe also go here could I add
that
just add more roads and I wish
like can I get y'all
down here
just so that
there's another means to get down this
way right
it's I did something something has
occurred
you're having a tough time
so let's put a traffic light here as
well
this is clearly our main road right now
Hollywood Boulevard why can't red go
through Blues parking lot yeah it would
be nice would be nice
thank you Sachin am I interested in
joining inside games I am not they have
asked but uh as said to Lawrence whom I
love and love talking to video games
about
um I did games media for a really long
time and I don't have any interest in
doing it again
is the truth and the stuff that I do on
my own channel is
UM very different because
it is just that I only talk about the
stuff I want to talk about I am never
chasing
views I'm just having a good time and
something like inside games obviously
being
basically actual media
gotta worry about views and stuff and I
I love being in a position to only talk
about stuff I care about plus also it's
been weird for me to be part of an
actual news Outlet like that when I work
at a game developer full time that would
be strange in my opinion
we need more roads man
thank God 30 Road toss baby
this is a hell of a commute for you my
friend
cheese
okay
you can't even get over there right now
oh gosh
this new green business that opened up
is just ruining everything
this way for you to get there is
probably from up here
right
It's gotta be
and then I need to add that road back in
for these Reds when I get a chance
damn it
okay oh no I did I disconnected them
uh where can I cut down on roads right
now
if anywhere
look It's gotta be this green stuff for
now
I have to make that just go here
just so that I can build
Thursday's almost over
no it's not
the yellows aren't falling apart without
access just yet I'm just giving them a
little holiday
just a little holiday
it's fine
when do I get more roads
I would really like them oh no
you guys actually have a pretty Breezy
trip it's a long distance but it's easy
to get there
oh God I need roads
nobody's got a countdown timer yet we're
fine we're okay
[Laughter]
oh boy oh boy got out of hands so fast
didn't I just buy
20 roads I'm just waiting I'm patiently
waiting please please
let let us live
and I don't have a Motorway do I know
okay who had no no one has a timer okay
thank God all right
um okay well you need to be connected
you need to be connected and you need to
be connected and you need to be
connected and you both
also need to be connected
it's the easiest way to do that
um with a bridge across the river help
anybody
I only have two roads again damn
foreign
can I make the highway longer
[Music]
can I make the highway longer I can
Highway reconstruction baby
let's go
that'll help somebody somehow
I wonder if I can make this all a bit
smaller I probably can right like
somehow
there are cars there you'll be fine
[Music]
oh this congestion another Bridge would
be great no roads no roads again no
roads damn
oh
this way to cut down on them might it's
get rid of the grid isn't it
it's cut down on grid
[Music]
um
I don't know that that will help anybody
to be honest
I don't know that the bridge there was
was good for anyone
what would help you
another Highway probably
or this again that seemed to slightly
help I'm gonna do that oh damn damn it
it's so hard
I used to be a lot better at this it's
just been a while but it is a very fun
time
you need a monorail
grid doesn't pay off that well okay
I that time I just kept running out of
Roads so let's do that less shall we
um
great so far just keep it like this
of both you can use oh
I think I need to just prioritize
getting Rhodes that's it get more roads
[Music]
rather than trying to the highway helped
the highway helped I don't know guys
the highway was really helpful
oh I forgot that I can speed up time
diagonals
yeah that's true
like I could but yeah maybe I should but
in my head I was like they won't help me
how could they but they they probably
can
[Music]
I also like do that
just like get sexy with it
you know
like for sort of a
like this kind of a situation
all right hey let's get Covey
having fewer intersections on main roads
will help I don't doubt that my friend
[Music]
I don't doubt what you're saying is true
but it is difficult to avoid
um can we even do this right now okay
yeah we have a single Bridge
but I'm not gonna do that right now I'm
gonna do this
and you do have to be connected yeah
let's avoid the connection there though
like I've only got one Bridge
um
I feel like that's helpful at all you
being there is perfectly fine
[Music]
well that's just what I have to do right
now then
no real option there
um
I'm okay I'm gonna get weird you guys
that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna get
weird
it's gonna be weird
[Music]
we're gonna get all curly with it oh you
can't be connected to by Red yet okay
there
they're all like God we have to go to
work sorry about that y'all
beautiful
yeah I'm gonna make it curly this time
okay
let's do it
everyone who drives here is gonna be
like
design
and I love that for me
[Music]
foreign
still
[Music]
we are going all out uh we can do this
I think moving this bridge higher
actually might help I'm getting rid of
this bridge
I can't okay it won't let me
never mind
so far so good
y'all are only connected to yourselves
right now that's fine with me
pocket these Reds to like
not go there like if I can do that that
seems easier for the Reds
I think that that's what I'll do when I
get a next Bridge
really
well now they have to be connected
okay
it's probably not a great intersection
uh we want to do it up and around and
down like that
just
could just because
you are okay
30 row towels again
or do we want another Bridge
I was gonna where was I gonna put it
here
no
no I think we're gonna just I'm gonna I
think I'm gonna do the 30. oh
there you go
all right
um
I don't actually know if I can funnel
which cars go where but right now in
theory I'm just telling all those Reds
go there
does it work that way or do they just go
to whatever the nearest thing yeah
they'll go to just whatever the nearest
thing is
[Music]
okay
maybe we should give him just another
connection
all right that's rude but okay
I hate all of you I want you to know I
think you're all
very annoying
[Music]
I'm gonna do it again we'll get a
Motorway one day but today is not that
day
you know
this just because in case
and there's still a lot of traffic on
this road
can it be avoided maybe yes
maybe with that
[Music]
you over here you over here
think that can help the traffic a bit
okay
again very rude of all of you
who I don't have room for right now
hot damn
reptiles sorry it has to be
this got hectic quickly okay oh okay
okay
um
is there a way to keep these Reds out of
the traffic of the greens not really
I mean you can you can go there you'll
be fine
Bridge
don't have one
I still don't think you need an exit
you're fine you can stay that way
alrighty
this is getting traffic Jammy here
[Music]
still going with the road tiles I'm
still doing it
trafficky here
um
because of the Reds up here
don't make their lives uneasy and not
really
oh that's a journey
damn that is a hell of a journey that's
that's a long commute my guys
that is a long way to get to work all
right
what am I doing
uh I guess I guess you gotta go here
just here just just there just there
okay
maybe I'll just pop up
[Music]
can I help this by adding another road
not really
can I make you any better
[Music]
yeah some of you could go this this way
just here
and that kind of helps
nope doing it again
that's yeah that's still fine we don't
need another entrance View
the dark Blues
are having a tough time getting to work
some of them can go that way but that's
it's just a long way to go
that's why we need the highway
the yellows also have a long way to go
the red oh you guys are kind of okay
traffic here is still a big problem
this road too okay
put a traffic light in
there
and a traffic light in here
is there only one route for the blues no
there are two
hmm
can I get any of you there any faster
I'm doing it I'm doing it doing it
yep ah damn it I was just trying to pull
it in oh my God
one day one day
okay
I'm I'm not giving up it's gonna happen
um
I liked the ball Road strategy but I
think that I also
I wonder if I can group them I wonder if
I can make them stop sharing roads
let's
see how possible that is shall we
give it a try
see what can be done
again even though I as pre-faced earlier
I'm very bad at this game and games like
this my brain just doesn't work this way
I don't look at like circuits it doesn't
it's not I can't do it I'm great at
anything that's timing based
um not this not this
uh I still really enjoy it
really really enjoy playing it
keep the colors separate for as long as
you can alright
I will try
did I get further that time I wasn't
looking at what I got I wasn't like
looking at my
at my um
oh damn
we can't really keep them separate just
yet they have to
they have to go like this for now
and then oh no problem and then we can
fix it maybe but for now it does have to
be this way until I get more Reds
how long have I been playing this game
currently about 40 minutes I think
50 minutes maybe
probably 50.
all right
when I get more roads we'll take these
Reds this way
it should help
is that true Scotty screams that
happened I have no recollection of it
[Music]
okay y'all are now going
this way
that way no longer stop it
you're not allowed anymore
two
this way
you
make over here
um
cool great cool looking good
I wonder if I make this a diagonal okay
hear me out
if I
like make this as tight as possible
will that prevent
other buildings from being built
in inconvenient places
you know what need to intersect it all
like say I also put this here
instead of there
and that you can go there
will this keep them contained
it might
no you don't there's no no you
absolutely do not I don't know who you
think you are or what you think you're
doing okay we're also actually gonna
we're gonna change this nope
to make you
have to go this way
um
sorry up here and and and what do you
mean I'm out of Roads
how did I have how did I fit that road
no
hmm can you still get home you can okay
well that's good
I don't know how I did that I guess that
was shorter
we'll fix that when we get more roads
uh well thank you Scotty screams I I
appreciate that but also you're okay
don't worry about it
can you use roads to fill in spaces
where you don't want stuff that's
exactly what I'm saying Yaki that's what
I'm trying to do right now prevent stuff
from spawning
I thought was
I go like this
because if I make them like as close as
possible to each other
then maybe
um
other things won't spawn in their
vicinity
that was exactly my thought
go down
oh
damn you not um okay hang on then you
have to go like this so we can separate
you from damn
dance red
this red is a problem
uh crap
that has to intersect unless I can no it
has to damn it
all right you just gotta you gotta share
that right there
you gotta share it just right here
well there and this too damn dude the
plan fell apart so fast
this also has to intersect
but
still keep them kind of apart
[Music]
kind of
like let's do that anytime two colors
have to intersex let's give them a
traffic light
use a diagonal between the other two
Reds um like like uh
like this like
oh
excellent is there anything I can do
about this one
I think that has to be there
okay
you
thank you
I want the highway
let me just draw our Highway
that's what I'm gonna go for
just give me the highway so I can get
them right here
Motorway
we're doing it
straight to work baby
this is the only intersection
and I can't do anything about it because
of the way these two are laid out they
have to be like that
yeah there's nothing else I can do it
has to be that way
Sparrow it's been out of block out areas
um
[Music]
yeah I don't know what to block out is
the problem
like
I guess anything being around here would
really suck
for the Blues
uh
something here would be pretty
inconvenient
what weird City infrastructure
anything here would be a problem here
would be a problem
enjoy a random road citizens
this would suck this would suck okay
that's all I can do for now
this roads are when the taxpayers have
too much money
connect the lower light blue closer and
move the Red Road up
oh no so that's only there because
um I'm trying to separate the uh to stop
anything else from spawning
um that's it I all right those roads are
there to yeah stop anything else from
getting between the blues so I feel like
that's the right call so nothing else
can go there
everything is kind of hugging
buildings as much as possible
which I think
is an arcade plan
so now
okay
just think about this for a second
look I can connect you there
there there there
no more
I can't connect you
um okay
Ridge are Road tiles uh do we need a
bridge
yeah let's take the bridge
um
so what I'm thinking is to get the blues
up and around
and the red here
so that they are still
separate
that worked okay great
we need this red to be accessible by the
other Reds
that does that connect to the highway no
that will work
it's weird but it'll work does Red's
traffic
damn it
maybe uh I don't think I can move the
where the highway lands
I think I think once you put a highway
down yeah
um yeah there's no other way to connect
to it which is a shame
but it's functioning it's functioning
yeah Light blues are doing great I mean
Red's also a completely separate it's
only the dark blues and the yellows that
are actually
on top of one another at all
nobody reads do I have right now three
um
is there a way to make the Reds have a
slightly easier time
this is
I can't even get over there
I can't get there I don't have the no I
don't have the roads
I don't have the roads
damn it
okay get we gotta we gotta delete all
these weird spare roads
Blues you're still fine you're still
you're still okay
we're gonna
okay this has to go now
to make my life easier
you hang on I supposed to get rid of
this and this
I need to go damn it
as many roads as possible okay here and
here
I can't let you move yet bud
is there anything else
like super unnecessary I can delete oh
well this could go this way
this one
so you can go here
you'll get that just not yet uh
to make this easier on a new one
[Music]
yeah I probably make this a tiny bit
shorter
all right what wait what I'm not getting
back the roads I destroyed
okay do we need traffic lights anywhere
no that this is still the only bad
intersection
that I can't do anything about
can you bridge the left side of dark
blue
connect the two big Reds Bridge left
side of dark blue
connect two big Reds
um I'm trying to keep the red separate
which they are
green separate yellows
that's enough you can stay like that
okay
as long as it doesn't break this which
it's not yet
um but we're probably going to want to
hide away these two Blues to be honest
oh that sucks
that's a shame
[Music]
that's a real shame
why'd you have to do that
I have no roads
so
damn
these yellows are going to need to
connect soon too
I'm all out of Roads
I'm so lost without you
this was mean
as many roads as possible okay we can
connect you but we don't really need to
wait this dark blue what no no no no you
go up here
and in theory over here but that's
probably not a good idea
um all of these Reds oh okay oh okay my
guy all right [ __ ]
all right they have to overlap with
green
unfortunately
for the world's busiest intersection of
all time
uh okay
like that and then like that let's just
look it's just a little estate
it's just a nice little estate
this is still only red and green though
which is cool Blue's still by itself
yellow and dark blue
it's all right it's okay
you don't need to go to work yet
thank you limbo I appreciate that thank
you yes I got promoted
a couple of weeks ago which is awesome
thank you Ray guno it's a cul-de-sac
exactly
[Music]
this sound is very satisfying right now
I'll say that much
what was I worried about connecting
the highway was that for that
just to get these guys right out here
and get rid of this I don't think that
really helps that much
um
you can visit each other
but you have no external visitation
rights
Highway that to that Highway that to
yeah probably
oh Highway the greens here to the green
there
and then I could save a lot of Roads
[Music]
oh thank you Cody thank you so much
thank you my friend
all right I'm gonna I'm gonna
the two
why
there we go
okay damn you no of all things shut
absolute shot
come on now green
that's that's evil
[ __ ] okay
damn
you have to you have you have to can you
get there from here I don't have another
Bridge you have to go this way that's a
disaster
that I will fix later
and I guess you guys also really just
need to
be dealt with
yokes
thank you Alex Jane yes the game is on
obviously PC what else is going on let
me double check
it is on
uh Apple arcade steam Nintendo switch
okay did anything else show up no
this green is a jerk
that's my hot take
and these Reds are also checks
I'm wondering if I get another Motorway
do I do greens
to probably right they're causing so
much traffic
I go from just another green one
and then at some point Reds but
the reds are just kind of doing okay
the reds are all right
okay uh we're gonna go with another
bridge for now so
[Music]
you can at least do
this does that help
yeah
can I disconnect that
does that hurt anybody
I just don't need the road for that blue
to get up there
I don't think that hurts anyone
[Music]
this one's having the most trouble right
now huh
foreign
is there a reason I can't yeah because
of the placement of that I can't really
get the blues there any faster
that one just is what it is
unless I could like Circle that up
around
that might work
okay okay
give me a minute okay I'm gonna do that
and then we're gonna change this
entrance
to be up up here
so it can be taken off of here
so then
the right
that's
keeps the yellows all happy
yeah okay
um
this blue is is definitely going to be a
problem though
put you up this way
uh
It's gotta just go right across it has
to
no Bridge no Bridge okay
okay okay
so for now
Blues
I've got to be able to just get there
why do we can't be placed here
that wait I did just move the entrance
to the motorway okay move it uh hmm
give me another mode away
okay
this needs to be fixed
where can I put you that would be
helpful
okay we're going to remove you from the
grid you're off the grid my friends
new community here we go
that is going to
connect
you from here hang on are you here to
over here
beautiful
I think I think that's beautiful I'm
pretty sure that's beautiful I beauty is
occurring does this green need to go up
here
not anymore right
these Blues
whoa the Reds out here are really having
a time okay you suck you suck a lot
stupid yellows
okay
[Applause]
I'm gonna go through here just
still think
oh no
uh okay cool we've gotta just connect
you've gotta be connected
uh
did that even connect no because I ran
out of tiles all right
foreign
way to make that smaller no oh God
oh God the Blues
it's just one I just I just
because they can only get to that one
that's the problem
um that's a very full parking lot can
any blue get to you yeah they're just
really far away damn it I'm so bad at
this
oh